okay we are live episode number 109 with
the great daniel de martino booth with
the biz doc and tz tom zenner in the
house
so uh excited to do episode 109 this the
first week we've done three back to back
to back yesterday we had john e deaton
on
representing xrp guys we can hear you if
you're speaking in the background okay
we had john eden on
and then uh tuesday we had matt zeller
on and today obviously this is it so we
got a lot to cover uh danielle before we
get into it
uh uh our buddy uh uh uh adam i don't
know if you saw that uh tyler adam had a
message for you did you guys see that or
no no adam was at his house oh
extremely focused he's listening right
now did you did you see the story or no
he
so
who is that who's audio is that mine or
is that yours or is that who's is that
because i'm off
i hear the audio do you guys hear that
don't know there's like an interview
going on in the back yeah i hear the
audio in the background it's not us
you guys turn it down okay was it you
tyler okay good all right so if you want
to see the story uh tyler i want to text
it to you
uh uh it was very important for adam for
us to show it because everybody's asking
which one do you want me to send it to
by the way vt macbook pro okay it's
coming your way this is to danielle
and the rest of the vitamin audience i
can't get like you know i can't have
like an allergic reaction to a virtual
cat tyler try to not show any of the
private mario videos anymore it's a
little awkward but
i press play
adam's definition of a productive day
and being productive
can your dog do that
[Laughter]
he's so proud though
this is the cat catching the nerf
basketball okay that's really um
adam i think you need to get out more
danielle how many alpha male do you
think wake up playing with their cat
like that i mean that's just to me it's
inspirational if you ask me there's a
market for it well it's amazing
i i can tell you this much there's one
there's one market for sure there's one
person in the market no i i think how
about adam can't even get the ball to
the rim that's the problem i've got a
good i've got a good uh hanukkah already
come and gone however for next hanukkah
i was in paris and this guy was walking
around with um he had on a backpack yeah
and the front of the backpack was a
plastic bubble
that you the clear plastic bubbles it
was like a backpack that you wear it on
the front of your body it's kind of like
a
you carry a baby or something baby
snuggler a baby not that i ever did that
um and then inside of the bubble was a
cat
so the guy was effectively taking the
cat out for a walk just to do some
sightseeing what a sweetheart
and i'm like what the that's a
sweetheart though and i'm like
scrambling to get my phone and take a
picture because i'm like nobody's going
to believe this well did you hear the
story about the woman getting kicked off
the plane because she was nursing her
cat on the plane yeah that was a legit
story about a month you know what you
know what adam did adam found out her
name and he dm'd her i don't know if you
know that or not true story anyways adam
we love you we miss you is dm a
technical term is who
is dm
yes is that like is that like decline
it is a technical term anyways we got a
lot of stuff going on we got uh
apparently tim cook reportedly signed a
secret 275 billion dollar deal with
china 2016 to skirt some government
regulators who knows if this is a story
or not we'll cover that the federal
reserve we want to get an update from
you on what's going on with inflation i
heard something the other day that
goldman sachs is predicting seven
seven rate hikes by the federal reserve
in 2020 see if you can uh uh uh have
some some thoughts on that 22 right 2022
low literacy levels amongst u.s adults
could be costing the economy 2.2
trillion a year you got something to say
about that
white house says restarting student
loans is a high priority sparking
outrage tom ellsworth's got something to
say about that and then blumenthal
speaks at the communist party award
ceremony that's a very very weird cuomo
ordered to return to 5.1 million
pandemic book profit he made and then
pelosi rejects stock trading ban for
congress members of congress we are a
free market economy they should be able
to participate in that so having said
that danielle won't you give us an
update on what's going on with the
economy today
well uh let's um
let's bring up the chart let's start off
today by bringing up the chart
because believe it or not what's going
on with the economy has a lot to do with
how much money the government is giving
people and people don't have a good
appreciation for that we're actually
starting to see shipping rates turn
and this is a global phenomena we're
starting to see inventories build this
is a global phenomena so the supply
chain disruption that we've been talking
about for the last 18 months it's
starting to dissipate and companies have
gone from just in time to just in case
so you don't want to build up stockpiles
by the way that's not good business
practices and yet so many companies are
on the fiscal front though if you look
at what
beef inflation was damn near 25
year-over-year forget the 6.8 percent
forget that but poultry was up 14
year-over-year i mean we're talking
about
monumental moves in the most essential
prices
we know housing prices are through the
roof however there's a reason there's a
reason that we're seeing inflation to
the extent that we are and it has
everything to do with fiscal policy run
amok so this is the
the supplemental nutrition
assistance program
and this it used to be called food
stamps yep
on the day that biden
said had to walk back and say
i meant what i said august 6 16 about
afghanistan
he had a new york headlines hit right
then and there new york times headline
hit that said snap benefits to increase
32 in the biggest increase in the
history of the program
so he signed an executive order in
january and he said let's revisit the
food pyramid and see how much money we
really need to give families and by the
way
in
oh
in in right but right before the
pandemic we were kind of in the hundred
and ninety dollar
range-ish 125 range this is per person
can you explain to the average person
what this is this is the average benefit
that an american receiving what we used
to call food stamps gets deposited to a
debit card on a monthly basis okay so
this is this is this is uh uh food
stamps being given away given away to
the average person right okay in in in
august when he was when the
international community was enraged
because of how badly afghanistan had
gone yep
the executive order all of a sudden the
report was ready to be rolled out that
same day that said we're going to give
people 32 percent more 32 percent so
they buried it essentially
october the 1st
data are not available
but this is this is an extrapolation if
you will because we only have data
through september but if you extrapolate
what the average
u.s household was getting
give or take
uh 400
you bump it up 570 dollars
per household that's
got like two kids per household add that
to the average of 550. that 61 of the 73
million children in america are getting
the child tax credit
of u.s households with children are
getting cash from the government
yesterday was the last payment
and you add these two up 90 90
in 2019 there were 73 it's hard to
believe in 2019 there were 73 million
children in america we know that since
then the birth rate has declined so that
73 number is probably high and
immigration has crashed so but
as of as of december the 15th the last
cash payment that we know is going to
occur without build back bigger
as of december the 15th the average u.s
household was getting 550 in cash 90
61 million of the 73 million children in
america families who do not need the
money period end in addition to that the
cares act greatly expanded the
percentage of americans who are eligible
for
assistance with with buying food
so on october the 1st we don't have the
data yet the benefits went up by 32
again
you hear these anecdotes if you're if
you're joe q household in america and
you're getting 1100 in cash at a minimum
a month
and you your spouse can stay home
which means you don't have to pay for
child care are you ever going back into
the workforce
so probably probably not for core jobs
under 50 000 a year exactly because it
doesn't make economic sense and that's
the line they've done the math so
they're giving people so much money that
that the fraud is rampant
if you're joe q with five kids
and you're getting
fifteen hundred dollars a month
times two
if you're joking what do you do with all
this money on a debit card to buy food
right when you don't want to buy that
much food
you sell it to your sure you sell it to
your liquid uncle for 50 cents on the
dollar you got eight thousand dollars
sitting on this debit card like what the
hell am i gonna do with eight thousand
dollars i don't want food i want other
things but is this stopping
no this is not stopping that's why we're
about to chart
there's some emergency measures in there
that are going to decrease
so what you're saying is to divert from
the afghanistan
i'm just i'm just saying that it was a
coincidence that he happened to roll out
on the same exact day right that he had
to he had to say i stand by my destiny
august 16th got it got it so it's one of
those coincidences like dropping a new
store at four o'clock on friday and the
other tricks that our government does to
kind of divert the distraction so we
could debate the traction but on that
day they raised it and it was not
temporary it's permanent and so you have
people that are getting a tax credit
simply because you check the box that's
how you fill out your taxes and the tax
software does it automatically and then
you that's the half you're talking about
and the other half is these debit cards
that are out there for the other half of
them because 90 american households
don't have one of these debit cards
this is not 90 of the child tax credit
so you're talking 90 of you are getting
and then tax credit that your that your
your tax guys quicken software
automatically puts on because it's part
of the regulation and then the other
half is getting these cards and these
cards are now up to this to the point
that there's a secondary redistrict
redistribution model where people are
monetizing it and selling it to you and
i'm not saying that this is the norm but
i'm just i was in austin for the for
down the middle austin series last week
and we're i mean to hear the anecdotes
of somebody with eight ten thousand
dollars built on on a debit card you
sell it to your uncle who's liquid
your uncle gives you 50 cents on the
dollar so you've got cash to buy
whatever you want
all the all the bad goodies in the world
all the good goodies in the world what
does your uncle do are those debit cards
only they're anonymous they're anonymous
okay they're interchangeable so what is
your opinion there's not a name on there
no you just use it at use almost like a
gift card when you go to check out
you can buy a cold sandwich but not a
hot sandwich
and you can't buy booze and you can't
buy cigarettes you can't buy anything
that's bad for you right you only bought
standard food at right there at the
little checkout at kroger you would just
use it and they have no clue that you're
using so basically a card that's
approved gentlemen i have a quick
question before we before we jump in if
you're the uncle who just paid paid 50
cents on the dollar for this card
what's for dinner
is it is it ground beef
or is it waiku
whatever they're hungry for exactly
because they've just paid 50 cents on a
dollar for cash why is why is beef
inflation up 22 year-over-year
why is a pound of bacon 9.99 but here's
here's what happens with this this is
when you get destroyed in midterms you
know destroyed yeah destroyed so the
point the point is there's cause and
effect the great thing about the system
is there's cause and effect you can do
all of this free stuff thinking it's
gonna work and then you realize the math
doesn't make any sense and then you get
destroyed and then everybody says it was
your fault and then they gradually
distanced themselves from you because
god forbid if a person has seen that say
biden camp and you're a congressman
trying to run again
you're like if you're part of his camp
you're not going to get reelected you
notice a lot of people are not getting
around him today they're trying to stay
away from ncnn yesterday i don't know if
you guys saw cnn yesterday they made a
uh
uh story they talked about the fact that
uh who are some potential candidates to
replace biden right they're already
talking about they were taking a huge
deal out of that yeah
and did you hear what one person came
out and said yesterday that said if it's
going to be a consequential event if
this person gets reelected you know who
that legendary person was that said this
the sweetest human being in the world
the most beloved person in america who
is more ambitious to want to be a
president than anybody else we have
currently in america that didn't get
there but newsweek did a special
magazine on this individual saying madam
president do you know who that person is
hillary clinton yeah exactly imagine if
hillary runs again in
2023-2020
so anyway so the point is you can do all
this stuff all you want but you're not
going to do well right and you're going
to get crushing midterms so keep doing
it yeah and you know danielle the key
word that you threw out there was fraud
because this thing is just ripe for
fraud you know you game the system last
fall so when i was not just right the
fruit's being picked you're correct
so when i was going back and forth from
dallas to l.a last last year the final
four months of the year i was going back
and forth every single week every single
week the planes were full right and this
is when travel was shut down and i could
not figure it out i mean why are the
planes full coming back from dallas to
l.a you can't go anywhere the city's
shut down there's nothing to do finally
this really smart guy informed me what
was going on and he was an uber driver
the la the massive level of fraud that
was going on with the handouts last year
on the debit cards people would fly in
that have never been on a plane before
by the way a lot of these people have
never flown anywhere they come to la
uber drivers pick them up and drive them
from atm to atm they withdraw 300 at a
time on these fraudulent cards and then
they rent big houses in the hollywood
hills and throw these huge parties they
rent luxury cars for two to three
thousand dollars a day and that's what
was going on for four months billions
and billions and billions of dollars in
fraud with that handout program last
year all right by the way a few people
got arrested and they went to jail for
it i mean there's major stories
i'm going to pose a question to tom
because he got one step in front of me
because you were you were going right
where i was going because patrick
started up by saying where's the us
going it's it's trouble when you
compliment time no no because it's over
especially at the beginning of the show
we're done he he knows what's happening
this is my sister from another mother
we're thinking the same way he knows
what happens on
okay so if you're joe q i've been
collecting the child tax credit in cash
do you still anticipate that you're
going to get your big tax refund on
january the 31st when you go to h r
block wherever you go to electronically
file your taxes are you still planning
on getting that tax refund like in
general or that day no just in general
the middle class and the slightly upper
middle class that's using hr block they
still think it's coming so they still
think the income tax refund absolutely
but the child tax credit has been paid
out in cash
post facto past tense
so we're talking about whoopsie
and anne biden wants to to start paying
back
student loans on february the first
right at the same time that people are
not getting their income tax refunds
that they were thinking that they were
going to get to pay off their credit
card debt from christmas
oh it's just going to be
too fire up the printing presses more
money
the republicans don't even have to they
don't have to hire an advertising agency
for the for the primary season patrick
is correct you can just sit back and
just and say 61.
well and then you couple all that with
the crime right and then it's a toxic
you're absolutely right well pat made a
point a minute ago he says hey you can
keep doing this for free this
what they have done on fiscal policy
during this reaction to covet and they
have pushed the free pendulum all the
way over here it's a combination of free
and printing money and they pushed it
over here all of a sudden that pendulum
is going to be too heavy and it swings
back the other way it has to it has to
and they can spin it all they want and
saki can say whatever she wants from the
podium and the average person is telling
you my milk is now six bucks a gallon
the average person is telling you my gas
is expensive and those are the people
that are going to the polls so you can
spin it any way you want but the charts
are speaking truth and pat's you're
absolutely right it's coming
let me ask a different question so i
remember we were in the army okay and
you'd go into formation you had a long
weekend you partied hard and one weekend
i'm doing guard duty and we had this one
guy if i say the name no one's gonna
know what this guy's but his name was
jackson only the guys that were at the
unit would know
this guy was chris tucker
uh combined with dave chappelle
hilarious guy but he loved smoking weed
and in the army you couldn't smoke weed
if you did you get caught you know
you're going getting an article 15 and
uh et cetera et cetera and we had
another guy i can't say his name because
his last name is very unique he was a
cocaine guy so
on one end of the hall we had a mountain
of cocaine i walked in one i'm like dude
what are you doing he said but david you
can't tell anybody dog you know
how the hell do you have this much
cocaine you only make 800 bucks a month
how do you he says well such and such
gave it to me we followed it's a
distribution deal anyways so he said
such and such gave it to me but anyways
don't tell anybody you want something i
said no bro i'm totally fine but you
know what please get rid of this stuff i
think you're clinically
the most thing you need
so now i go back to the other side so
one end the door's open they're doing
coke the other end smells like freaking
bob marley showed up out of nowhere and
resurrected and they're smoking nons and
by the way the worst part is smoke's
coming from the bottom of the what do
you call it the the door right that's
good i'm like jackson you're making i'm
i'm responsible
i got guard duty bro you're ruining my
life right now i'm gonna get in trouble
he says dude david dawg you can't do
nothing man you gotta tell them i'm not
doing nothing i said i said here's what
i need you to do i can tell them
anything but their noses knows so i said
dude light up incense everywhere
so he says okay okay uh yeah good idea
dog so i go grab my incense i get
everybody to get him insane he's got 50
likes
you should see this place makes no sense
so sergeant calls me
uh david
yes sarge i'm coming through oh my god
listen i would suggest we start off with
the one that's the most troubled one
which is charlie company which is the
one that's the most peaceful very easy
gold star tactic right so we start with
charlie and i'm taking my temp i think
we have to be careful with this floor it
was filled with you know christians and
mormons they were good kids right so i
said but you got to be careful with
these guys because you know how they are
sometimes there's a bottle of jelly
rollers
so anyways we go to second floor i'm
taking my time i'm like dude i got like
if i can 45 minutes i open the windows
everything anyways he says we got to go
to hht cause jackson's there so jackson
is the biggest sweetheart what are you
talking about
david you and i know who jackson is i
said dude
so we go there and we were walking up he
said what's that smell i'd say they were
barbecuing earlier
he said no i smell wheat i said no it's
incense incense smells very similar
so he goes and you see the smoke coming
out of jackson's deal
dude he knocks on the door opens the
door
what's up sarge oh god
jackson wipe that look off your face so
he's got two other buddies that's
sitting there and uh
you guys smoking wheat me
i don't smoke then we
talking about this
we're reading poetry this is incense
i'm like no no listen let's just go the
other way let's go the other way because
no no they're smoking with us so sorry
they're not smoking wheat he said
they're smoking with us what are you
talking about it's incense you ever had
smuggled this it doesn't smell so
anyways we leave so at this point i'm
thinking i got away with it we go to the
other side the cocaine guy covers it up
okay which by the way ended up going to
jail for like five years military prison
bad situation because he wouldn't stop
doing cocaine you're not supposed to do
it in the army you're not supposed to do
it period but in the army it's even
worse
anyways we go to formation we can ants
we're like guys hey big dog we made it
man you're my homie i'm like dude we
made it we're straight up
so monday morning all right um
we're doing a random drug test
if you're social the last four of your
social starts with the number six
and four
step up so whose numbers are they it's
jackson's mine and the other guy
so i'm like hey i know i'm clean so i
step up i'm like oh jax oh dog i
don't know i don't have the what do you
call the the thing you would pour on
your uh
uh a vinegar it didn't have the vinegar
because you have to tip it and then
anyways anyway we're learning a little
too much here so yes dude i don't have
that you gotta say dude i'm not gonna
have any so anyways we'll go get tested
and the way they test it the way they
test it is they're watching it's not
testing it go give them no no they're
not doing that so put your hands on the
side one hand only let me see very
awkward
so we come out
he said what do you think is going to
happen i said
either they're going to you're going to
test positive for incense or are you
going to test positive
or
barbecue so the cocaine guy doesn't get
tested for nothing he gets away for
whatever reason he didn't get him well
they got him six-month city but they
didn't get him that time he just
couldn't hopefully help himself he was
too pretty with a guy and he party i
introduced him to one club and he just
went crazy jackson gets caught
and he goes demote gets commodity from
specialist on e1 okay
and he has to do bathroom you know all
this stuff he has to clean up he said
i'm like jackson i told you bro so i
come up clean everybody's good we leave
jackson's out the other guy goes to
military prison and people have to
figure out probably not a good idea to
smoke weed and do cocaine in the army
right
i come out of the army i talked to one
of my friends who him and i worked at
burger king together he was the cashier
and i was the chef
and so
they wouldn't make me cashier they said
you talked too much
that's a big word i was a chef listen i
like being a chef it's
whopper no audience right
so one day we get into the biggest
debate about welfare and social security
and all these section 8 and all this
stuff i said you know what i think they
need to do he says what biggest debate
i'm curious to know what you guys will
say
i said i don't mind if you're giving
unemployment benefits to people some
people need it for three six months they
recover i told you you need to give
welfare and food stamps to certain
people but here's what i think they need
to do what's that i think
every month you ought to get drug tested
if you test positive you don't get
taxpayer money
if you test negative listen we'll help
you out but there's one criteria you
cannot do drugs he lost his mind he says
that's not fair
what would it take if we were to drug
test people that are getting
you know whatever it is wig any of this
stuff that we're getting what percentage
of people do you think wouldn't get the
benefits
well you know through the 80s and 90s
you know you would have a tremendous
percent of people under 30 that test
positive marijuana and don't get the
benefits and now you've got 25 states
where it's perfectly legal to go get
high and just go buy it at the drug
store you can get edibles and whatever
you want the you know process
but what you're using is in order to
qualify you have to yeah
90 percent
you know i don't think it's that high 90
degrees no no i was going to say a fifth
dude i've
not adam adam right now is rolling i
don't think it's 90 percent no i i would
say at least a third i'm gonna go with a
third i think that's conservative okay
let's just say a high of 90 which i'm
sure he's being conservative in his mind
was that a pun you're a third let's say
let's
let's say third there's a delayed
reaction this morning with patrick
you don't understand let's say a third
is he related to charlie tom help me out
here are you really serious you only
think one third of people that get these
three benefits i don't do all month
are only a third of the time how about
we say 50 okay let's just say 50. at
some point during the month they would
test positive if they hit it up
90. let's say you're really jacked up
about this i thought high 90 was a fast
ball but now you're talking about drug
percentage let's say 50 let's say 50
what do you think would happen if that
was a standard he said look no problem
you're going through tough times my rule
for unemployment how people want to get
unemployment here's my unemployment
would work what were you making at your
job four grand a month how much is
unemployment we're paying you two grand
a month that's it no problem here's what
i want you to do you're four grand a
month you were working uh 40 hours a
week i was the two grand we're giving
you unemployment i want you to give 20
hours of community service exactly and
we'll pay you two grand a month but 20
hours of community service as long as
you're not disabled you know how quickly
people would get off of unemployment oh
my gosh
we need community service the side of
the freeways are dirty bro we need your
help but you're so awesome we'll give
you this two thousand dollars in
exchange and a drug test once a month
and totally do that here's your
reflective vest and your orange bag and
people would be like the side of the
freeway going my friends on this freeway
texting i do not want to be here they
would be off unemployment in 10 seconds
yeah that's the point so the point is do
you want people off of unemployment do
you want people off of welfare do you
want people not you
politicians establishment do they want
people off of entitlement programs no or
do they meet them
programs voters this is better but look
at look look at the gray lines it's been
true that's the unintended consequence
that's food at home inflation it is and
that's this is a government program
making inflation higher than it would
otherwise be which is the most
regressive tax in the world inflation
let me ask you this question yeah
because the people that are putting
these policies together have smart
people around them or they are smart
they're not idiots
do they think we're idiots and that
they're just going to force feed us this
as long as they possibly can is this is
this a day-to-day game for them just to
stay relevant and to be re-elected or do
they think these policies work well let
me let me ask you a question when it
comes down to parents you think parents
are smart or you think they're dumb i
think they're smart okay good all right
let's let's qualify all parents are
smart okay do you think some parents
uh uh who say a father who has not been
on a picture comes back he wants to win
the kids over how do fathers try to win
their kids over money money attention
what do kids later on say in life when
they have that one big fight with their
father stop trying to buy me with what
with gifts right when people grow up
some kids are gonna be like dude i love
it
give me more gifts this is great but
some kids say what i don't want you i
don't want you to love me with money i
want you to put some time into me and
help me grow up you were not there for
that time there's going to be a
percentage of people that are going to
be like this this political party is
awesome this is great i'm loving this
but there's gonna be a few people that
are gonna be like listen i'm sick and
tired it's i'm sick and tired
of it listen i got it i got it you can't
buy me with money i don't want any of
these entitlement programs i mean again
61 of these 73 million children in
america 90 what percentage of americans
know that they're getting money that
they don't need and are pissed off a lot
i mean i heard people well i don't know
about pissed off because probably but
you know
i've heard people say like why isn't
this money going to people who really
need it why am i getting this money i
don't know that that's a reaction i hear
people say that all the time i just got
a deposit i i don't know why they're
sending me money right i mean people
that probably don't need it they're
still getting the handoff yeah you know
it's crazy we had a board meeting last
week tom was in the room and one of my
investors gets up and he says you know
last year i called pat and i called pat
i said hey they're getting away the ppp
loans okay and we can get pretty much
free money i said what's the number he
says a little bit less than 5 million
bucks we can get if we go get it but
remember we don't have to pay this back
i said why are we
why do we take the money he says listen
just take the money you don't need to
worry about it because
we don't have to take it back you can i
said take the money and run i said i'm
not doing it bro it says so then they
call another board member to call me and
say we should take this money i said we
have money why am i taking 5 million
bucks he said because they're doing it
for everybody and i said i'm not going
to do it so he brought up this story to
say pat didn't want to take it why am i
taking the money if i if i'm going to be
fine i don't need this money give it to
people that are struggling the
restaurant owner that's getting crushed
right give him that exactly they need
tremendous help exactly we're going to
be okay well the board should be happy
that you took that stance integrity you
know well
sure but that board member is a very
very uh driven uh by the numbers guy and
i love him but he's a business guy great
guy by the way fantastic guy but uh it
is what it is anyway so we'll see what's
going to happen here with these numbers
and the direction inflation is going so
having said that having said that
uh inflation surged to 6.8 in november
okay even more than expected to fastest
rate since 1982
federal reserve is expected to take a
very big step towards a rate hike it's
what they're talking about right now
this is a cnbc story uh they're about to
announce a dramatic policy shift
wednesday that will clear the way and
they did first interest hike rate next
year markets are anticipating the fed
will speed up the wind down of its bond
buying program changing the end to march
in uh from june that would free the
central bank to start raising interest
rates from zero and fed officials are
expected to release a new forecast
showing two to three interest rate hikes
in 2022 and another three to four in
the big wild card for markets is what
the fed says about its balance sheet
which was 4.1 trillion dollars in
january the 2022 before pandemic was
swollen to eight point seven trillion
dollars you just mentioned that there
was uh
one set of analytics that said that
expecting as many as seven mini hikes
during the year no no i said that i said
goldman
well listen yesterday was a shock a
shock for the markets and
fed officials are being so aggressive
because they they announced that the the
median probability is now three rate
hikes according to fed officials
according to the dot plot according to
the anonymous votes so a a preponderance
of the the the officials on the federal
reserve board are now anticipating three
rate hikes next year but as we see
fed hikes
seen starting with yield curve flattest
intergeneration
it's a wonky thing to discuss but the
reason stocks are up is because stocks
are like they're not going to be able to
do it
because
we we've had the difference between the
two-year treasury yield and the 10-year
treasury yield which is by the way what
i spent all of 2019 talking about i
spent all of one whole year talking
about the damn yield curve but we've had
the difference between the two year and
the 10-year yield go from 161 1.6
percentage points in april at the peak
of the stimulus stimulus checks 3.0 to
where it is today half of that 80 basis
points so it's been cut in half so it's
a record decline once that yield curve
gets really flat
it tends to say we're going into
recession so the markets yesterday were
like
they can try and raise interest rates
all they want but they cannot raise
interest rates if the yield curve is
flat or even worse inverted because that
signals a recession so try me go for it
hurry up with the taper right now
they're on track because they've doubled
the size of their the reduction in
purchases
to from 15 to 30 billion dollars
starting in january so they're on track
to finish with the taper to stop going
the balance sheet by march 15th at the
rate that they have announced officially
yesterday so in theory on the march 17th
meeting two meetings from now they could
launch the first interest rate hike but
let's go back to tax season and the
money that people are not getting back
in interest in in in income tax refunds
yeah and the child tax credit not being
paid january the 15th for the first time
and biden
seeming to pull it out of his
the february the first student loan
repayment let's talk about what the
first quarter of this economy is going
to look like and whether the fed's going
to be able to do a single interest rate
despite inflation which there's a word
for it it's called stagflation and it's
the worst of all possible situations
because your growth is slowing while
prices are still running it's the
hardest to break and it is the hardest
to break and wait till people start
getting their energy bills over the
winter
they're going to get hammered it's cold
forget it game over
you know when it comes to the biden
administration is going to be praying
for covet strain number six to distract
the american people from the fact that
a multi-point assault on the economy is
happening how bad do you think it's
going to be how bad do you think that jp
morgan came out yesterday morning and
they said you know what our health care
conference is going virtual so let's try
and multiply that out right when
travel's coming back right when right
right when all the everything in person
conferences i mean i've got them lined
up that's one of the biggest of the year
about it that's in san francisco i
believe it is now virtual
could you imagine if people had access
to these types of conversations a year
ago right before the election do you
think it would have changed people's
minds knowing where the economy was
going because a lot of people predicted
this this isn't something you don't
executive ordered the usda into
increasing the food stamp program at 32
percent this is i mean this is like
what's being done to the us taxpayer
quietly is is just criminal
and you just need more people to talk
about it and i'm telling you 61
seats a 61-seat swing come november is
going to look like a walk in the park
well into what's going to happen the
narrative
the narrative's already shifted you can
tell and it's a story later if we want
to talk about it but even how some of
these liberal mayors are talking about
crime right now they're actually
admitting that it exists and you know
that's a preemptive strike for the
elections but when it comes to inflation
i think sure everybody has this but it's
true aha moment right when you realize
inflation is real for me it hit me the
other day i was at the grocery store i
bought two apples i was going to buy two
apples two apples it was like four bucks
four 450. i'm going for for two apples
what's in the apple
well jackson had hidden some marijuana
in there that's what i'm saying
i had to throw it over the wall
it's the secret special
[Music]
these apples i like them apples but
david is in fuego this morning but you
know i don't need those apples that bad
i don't need apples right that's a
ridiculous four or five pounds i didn't
buy this differently for two apples i
didn't buy the pound of bacon
somebody told me ten bucks for a bag of
oranges you have a problem with bacon
this guy's got a problem with apples but
by the way how are things in california
right now
you know you and i texted back and forth
the other day with the whole greats
where they're getting rid of
f's and some lausd and these right some
cities they're not going to do these but
how are things with crime street i mean
you've seen a lot of videos people are
walking and taking stuff but we're not
living in california you're there what
is it about dallas texas too i i know
four people that have been either held
up had a gun pointed at them something
violent a violent encounter and this
this is in beverly hills this is in the
past
i personally know them i personally know
people have had guns pulled on them
robberies around them you know i was
making a movie with alec baldwin
no actually he took a sabbatical um wow
we had a christmas party last week a
good friend in beverly hills and
literally i was thinking about it all
day i was thinking is there going to be
security there because literally they're
they're hitting holiday parties now
they'll come in
and they'll they'll watch his wallets
and rings it's happening it really is
and i literally asked him i said by the
way is there going to be security there
have they thought about hiring somebody
luckily it was in an enclosed condo
complex where you couldn't get in but i
was literally thinking about that all
day i think about that where where you
drive where you go people don't wear
their watches they don't wear they don't
carry expensive things you're you're a
walking target
and it's just it's really sad you know
they had huge smash and grabs over
thanksgiving like a lot of these big
cities did they rounded up they arrested
17 people garcetti goes in front of this
big press conferences they were all
released the next day zero cash bonds
it's really bad they're so brazen they
don't care they're organized and i think
it's starting to hit more influential
people in california that's why i think
it might start shifting a little bit
because it just makes no sense if you
think back and these they can go in and
steal whatever they want whenever they
want
in the most high traffic area it's a
great time for for citizen watches to
create a marketing campaign wear our
watches no one will steal them like a
very it's a exactly like the old swatch
from 40 years ago
hey pat you know we're talking about the
smashing grab you know the nordstroms
that's at west hills yeah it's right
it's on topanke canyon and it's the edge
of canoga park but it's bright by west
hills and
where all the celebs live you know
calabasas it was right next to that
that was the nordstrom that was hit so
they're coming to these areas oh it's
not it's not just
rodeo drive that's right the one in
topanga topanga plaza that's the main
it's now that's the best nordstroms in
l.a that's that's right and it's now
known as the westfield west hills
that's the one that got hit so when
there was police cars chasing them it
was a huge it was a chase this is not an
isolated incident when nordstrom's
reported their earnings they had a
special line item for theft that's how
much it's impacted nordstrom's earnings
they had a special one-line item for
losses due to theft and walgreens has
shut down hundreds of stores because of
that yeah and it's it's organized the uh
the tapanga one happened this way first
three came in with bear spray and they
hit the guards they walked in and this
was two girls one guy dressed reasonably
they
they had like you know they were wearing
like
caps and then pulled them down and then
they hit the guards with the bear spray
and then 20 people stream in and got all
the purses and stuff that can be sold
easily on ebay or with sidewalk vendors
down in venice hey you want a purse
yeah i mean it had a method point is
that there was a playbook for this it
wasn't just random i talked to i talked
to a big uh pr from yesterday in new
york and this is how the call starts
so
um my friend said you ought to get with
one of these bigger pr firms this is the
main person you gotta talk to us and no
problem so she gets on
and uh
uh she says uh so how are things great
so where are you at i'm like i'm in
south florida you know
things are great here oh i hear things
about south florida i'm like what do you
hear about south florida it's okay i
said how are things in new york oh great
i said ooh you know
it's great to be a part of it that was
the best city in the world just a couple
years ago pre-code oh stop exaggerating
still the greatest city i was on the
streets the other day people are walking
everywhere it's so free it's still the
greatest city in the world i'm like yeah
there's a lot of strange things going on
there and you saw her like she couldn't
help herself no this is still the
greatest city in the world and she's
going with this part i'm like
all right i said well awesome you know
more power to the great city there are
certain people that are trying to deny
what's going on in their cities new york
being one of them l.a being one of them
and the
newsome even came out and said i'm going
to follow uh what do you call it's a
protocol he says what texas is doing
with abortion i'm going to be doing with
gun laws is what we're going to be doing
remember he's ramming that through to
get rid of the automatic assault rifles
right in in la anyways
again they keep doing things like this
people are going to keep leaving people
will react there is cause and effect i
was i was in new york city yesterday i
mean i heard from a lot of my buddies no
i'm i'm i'm back back working at home
they shut down the office again because
they they imposed mass mandates inside
yeah
yeah la just shut down for another month
too mass indoors everywhere don't you
just love that it's like a way of saying
go spend time with your family
there's a level of nobility and news
some when you think about it you know
like these guys are they're so concerned
about your quality time with your family
but and nobility i never i never made
that connection yeah it's just it's it's
a sweet little thing that's going on
there so okay let's talk about student
loans uh white house says restarting
student loans is a high priority
sparking outrage okay tom this is a
story you have opinions on let me read
it first and then you can uh get right
into it it's a true uh truth uh uh uh is
that the one yes it is okay white house
secretary jen sackey recently announced
that the vitamin administration is not
planning on extending the student loan
payment pause
sparking outrage among debt advocates
and people who have struggled with
student loan repayments for years the
administration is planning to allow the
student debt payments paused to expire
at the end of january the pause which
was implemented to aid borrowers as the
economy was rocked by the pandemic has
been in place since march of 2020 2020
i'm angry at biden's backtracking on key
pillars he ran on cancellation i'm
fearing what the end of the moratorium
will do for so many people tweeted one
user other twitter uh user noted that
allowing repayments to start during a
critical election year is a poor
strategy for nation's top democrat which
she's right so thoughts tom what do you
think about this well there's like three
angles to this and the first angle there
is is
i think is political um and then the
other one is has a large banking and the
big numbers that you talk about right
now there's 1.7 trillion dollars of
student loans that is held by a
collective sum of about 43 million
you know
students that ran those up
so
you
the first thing you had is biden ran a
campaign promise when he was not yet the
nominee for president and he was
fighting against the bernie group that
was completely locked in the bernie and
the elizabeth group elizabeth warren and
so he said if i'm elected i will cancel
half of the student loan for the lower
half of more you know
you know economically
you know below some line
students half of them half of them okay
good well that would be
800 billion dollars and we just approved
a 2.5 trillion dollar debt increase so
where are you going to get the other
half you know 800 billion from it was it
would basically be tarp
for those that are carrying it you know
what the big three are navient wells
fargo and discover hold 40 of the
student loan debt so if you're canceling
the debt what you have to do you have to
do something for the not the servicers
but you got to do something for the
banking industry and guess what
that would impact the size of bbb and
that would also impact the
size of the recent increase on the debt
limit because it's all related this 800
billion is going to come from some of
there it is 1.73
and true yeah and then you'll find in
there about 43 44 million americans that
are carrying that yep 43.2 yep yep so
you there's
a big number so the first problem is
you know i'm not unhappy to see a civil
war inside the democratic party about
this because this is when the that all
the all the independents moderates and
the republicans kind of sit this one out
and they're watching the democrats you
know we're starting a civil war you know
what's the problem with giving things
away to people for free you know what's
the problem with giving money or things
away to people for free they just expect
more
somebody else's money you eventually
have to stop
that's correct do you understand what
i'm saying so for example i had a friend
of mine best friend in the world we went
to first grade together high school
together military meet everything no
cocaine
no cocaine this guy is not a cocaine guy
no so best friend
but because it's other things but
anyways
so but the friend at the other end of
the hall was the marijuana he was the
jacksons man i missed that guy so much
if i if he finds this i'd invite him to
tell these stories because he's that
funny okay tom stop okay so
so anyway so i'm uh uh uh
i'm i'm talking to this guy and he says
pat i'm going through tough times okay
never forget this i'm going through
tough times i said uh what are you going
through i can't pay the office rent i
said no problem i got you this month on
me
30 days later he makes money he buys a
nice 4 5 000 engagement ring for his
girl
rent comes he says i'm struggling as
well i said bro you just made i know how
much money you made yeah yeah he says no
no one more month so i said i had one
more month so at this point i'm getting
the good feeling of being a good friend
because he likes me do you know what i'm
saying it's like oh wow this is so
awesome what a great friendship we have
here right i'm bailing my friend out two
months three months it ends up being
eight months eight months later he
hasn't paid rent then i have to tell him
to do what
i the friend has to a victim
i have to tell him you cannot be in this
office anymore
after eight months of not paying rent
and evicting him guess who became the
enemy i'm the bad guy and he went
nuclear you know he went nuclear you
know my dad told me here's what my dad
told me says parent you're about to
start making money this is 13 years ago
14 years ago i'm 27 years old so 16
years ago he says you're about to start
making money he says when you start
making real money everyone's going to
call you you have to have a basic rule
when people call you for money i said
what's that he said when people call you
they'll say i need to borrow five
thousand dollars he says never give them
lend them five thousand dollars because
the fastest way to lose a friend or
relative right he said instead say the
following you need five thousand dollars
you wanna borrow five thousand dollars i
can't give you five thousand dollars
however i can give you three hundred
dollars and you never have to pay it
back so years no no but i need five
thousand i totally get it but the
difference is i don't wanna have hurt
our friendship right so instead of me
loaning you 5 000 here's 300 bucks but
never have to worry about paying it back
it's such a confusing situation because
i still helped
and you can't walk away upset right and
i'm still like helping out so you kind
of it's kind of like this it's like
okay sure you know what i mean you just
kind of walk away i think dems have
given so much that eventually eventually
you have to stop giving them money and
they're going to turn against you
was it chas who said when he made a
little bit of money he called all of his
friends
chaz palminteri made a bunch of money
apparently you know good he was working
on projects he earned it he was a great
actor and getting good roles and getting
good paydays so he said to preempt what
would happen in hollywood where people
ask him hey thirty thousand dollars how
about thirty thousand i got a script i'm
gonna finish it i'm gonna get
development deal blah blah blah blah
blah blah
instead of that what he did he called
all his friends after he borrowed twenty
thousand dollars and then they would
assume oh my god that's brilliant
brilliant
that is so good and then they didn't
call it a preemptive strike about to get
a million dollar check he calls all his
friends borrow him for 30 grand they all
say no
then he gets the million yeah then when
they called they said bro you said no i
can't i can't do it so and a great actor
can pull that off when i think of chaz
momentary i just him dropping the coffee
cup in the usual suspects when he sees
the names on the board and then
you're absolutely right and so to close
close close you know on student loans
you have a democrat civil war number one
number two
you can't throw another 800 billion on
the economy and number three
now you have a voting block that feels
that they
got screwed because they were promised
something and it's not there
here's why final caveat what about the
people that are going to school now i
mean are they going to be forgiven
going forward in perpetuity i mean what
if you're going to college in two years
and you have to take out loans you know
everybody else be before you had it
wiped away but you're going to be facing
i'm telling you this creates such a big
rift and a division it's not a pretty
side because you you eventually have to
say no this is why you have to position
yourself and no if you start now
it's just a matter of time before they
hate you
starting january the 15th january the
15th is the first month
the first day that people aren't going
to get the child tax credit january the
31st is when they find out that they're
also not getting an income tax refund so
there's going to be a lot of animosity
before we get to the first
month of the year
in the democratic party among the the
constituencies that they're trying to
buy their votes
pat we could go deep on this an entire
podcast maybe we should sometime because
it's also the inflation that's happened
in the cost of tuition is because the
universities know they're only
accepting ten percent of what comes in
so there's no problem with the demand
and they keep raising it because they
know that the federal government is
backing the student loans yeah and so
it's
the student loan program has been let's
go to the next story let's go to the
next story so from just the news home
prices at a 45-year high pricing many
buyers out of the market annual home
prices were 18 higher in october of this
year than they were last october and
we're also the highest recorded in the
45-year history of a home price index
published by global property company
corelogic arizona arizona idaho and utah
saw the highest home price increases
from october to october 2021 24
fannie mae's november forecast projects
a median price of a previously owned
home to surpass 400 000 by middle of
2023 that's insane if you think about it
i mean i know it's not a big number when
you think about some areas but it's
insane when it's across the board it
also projects that the median new home
price will reach 464 000
by the end of 2020 for roughly a hundred
thousand dollars more
than the new home prices in january of
i mean this is run off the rails and we
wonder why mortgage originations are
down three months in a row mortgage
origination is down three months in a
row
submits yep apps people putting in apps
i mean at some point you're going to hit
a pain threshold when it comes to the
price the sticker stock is going to get
you
car sales are down seven of the last
eight months i mean sticker shock is
real when it comes to these well part of
that's inventory too but who knows
if you if cox automotive put a story out
a few days ago and they anticipate that
this whole supply chain thing the supply
ch in autos is going to be unwound by
the first quarter you have lot after lot
after lot after lot in kentucky filled
with ford f-150 trucks waiting for one
chip but i mean they're i mean the
inventory is sitting there ready to go
so
no home prices are completely off the
rails we we we get a weekly report from
the mortgage bankers association to
fannie mae's estimate the median uh the
the average purchase loan
as of yesterday's data was 406
800.
the average home price in austin texas
median home price in austin texas 455
so the the the lower cost states are
pricing themselves out of the market
because californians are moving in and
they're like it's a buy one get one free
sale so they come in and they buy one
get because they do they do the tax math
of getting out from underneath that that
terrible tax burden
in california and they
they they're like i can buy this house
i'll give you two anecdotes real quick
shawn desant and kay our beloved aunt
kay former belly dancer by the way um
that makes her beloved exactly uh bought
a move moved to being in us when we were
living in phoenix bought a house i think
for about 140 140 000 sold it she moved
to missouri sold it for like 450 for had
a bidding war and then i had a friend
that goes to coeur d'alene idaho and you
mentioned idaho pratt in one of these
states where the prices are going crazy
so he used to go back and forth to coeur
d'alene a little vacation home then he
built a house recently within the past
year built it i mean beautiful like a
four seasons really nice interior guest
house the whole thing all in at 3.2
wanted to you know there's going to be
the place where they're going to spend
half the year constant knocks on his
door never put on on the market finally
someone knocks on the door and offered
him 7.5 million and he took the deal
didn't even live in the house for less
than a year someone offered him 7.5 and
he had to take the deal so it is crazy
it's absolutely bond montana is number
one there's there's a little town in
montana austin texas is number two boise
idaho's number three the three hottest
housing markets in america white fish
let me let me ask you uh how much has
rent up uh have you have you seen those
numbers okay so at least i'm looking at
the real.com i'm going to send this to
you if you want to kind of uh uh
matter of fact just go type in the
following type in is rent up just
tapping is rent up and then go to news
go to news
yeah news and then go to the second one
yeah right there we go this was fast
tyler this was the best one so far so
that was a good assistant
okay as rent explodes say there you go
as rents ex rent explodes nationally in
new york city tops the charts go a
little lower which one is one of the
biggest comebacks since you mentioned at
least last time the city apartments were
on discount rack rents had fallen 14 in
12 months since then gotham rents are up
32 fourth among u.s cities according to
a new report from zumper
uh the median price for one bedroom is
now 31.90 it's officially surpassed san
francisco nationally rents are up 11.6
percent above where they were last year
so okay so if
rents are up 11.6 percent but real
estate is up 20
uh uh what's the number 20 percent 25
percent 18 to 20 percent unless you say
nationally what what does that tell you
what does that tell you if the prices
are going at a faster pace than rent is
does that reveal anything
right now buying a house relative to
renting buying a house is the most
expensive it's ever
been as high as rents are
i've got i've got the data yeah and then
think about taxes and that is a brain
twister because the trends are going up
so so fast yeah so are you saying it's a
better time to rent than it is to buy
right now believe it or not
well but you have to remember rent
increases is a trailing indicator
because first you have the price
increase and one year after the price
increase you have the property tax
readjustment based on the sale sure then
you've got the insurance it increases
based on the the ad valorem the value of
the underlying assets and now the
insurance is up
so what happens is rents usually
increases usually follow housing
price increases like six to nine months
usually follow them and right now is how
many private equity firms are dedicating
themselves to real estate portfolios and
are buying up single-family units
there's 75 billion has been invested in
this single family
build build to rent
not buy to rent build entire communities
so
there's a suburb
property owners in the private equity
sector they're massive and the average
american is going to be pushed into
renting because they can't afford to buy
they can only afford to rent but then
the rent's going up so you asked about
rents so single-family homes because
this is a big wall street baby this
industry is loved by wall street so
blackstone has the largest uh
single-family rental home rentals i saw
that invitation homes so they're
bragging on their most recent earnings
call that for new leases
when they get a new renter in there
they're getting 18 19 percent
over the past year it's actually a
brilliant move 18 19.
your home ownership is going to drop
there are there are suburbs outside of
atlanta
there are certain there are certain
areas that that are starting to clue in
to the damage that these private equity
firms are doing and saying
go away i'm not permitting you i'm not
giving you the permits to build this
subdivision because you you effectively
create like this entire generation
of slaves and they're they're in the
right they're in the right school school
district
and they're in a home that their family
wants to be and they feel like they have
home ownership but they're actually
slaves to these massive
above market rents way above what you
would for a multi-family apartment
and but they don't want to move because
they're in the right school district so
and they never they're paying such such
high rents that they're never saving up
that three and a half percent for an fha
or 20 for a regular down payment
it's it's a it's a it's it's a way to
ensure that there's like a cycle of
poverty but but let me ask you this so
blackstone is not going to do this and
make an investment just because of 12
months they're not doing it for 24
months they've been doing it for years
yeah what i'm saying is if you're doing
that you're foreseeing
renters
surpassing buyers at a a tremendous rate
in the next five to ten years you
wouldn't do that just for one or two
years right that's but that's why
they're going into secondary and
tertiary markets that's why they're
building these communities in the
excerpts whatever is north of frisco in
in dallas they're building communities
in prosperity
but they're doing it because they have
to because lot prices are so high land
prices are so high that in order to make
these crazy internal rate of return
assumptions work which you're that's
what you're speaking to yeah that
they've got to go out into the damn
hinterlands schwartzman is a genius he's
not going to make a a this big of a bet
if he doesn't know it's going to be a
good bet for the next five times and who
just retired from blackstone
tony james the number two
and who sold the firm that i used to
work at tony james at the top of the
market in 2001. thank you are you giving
us something he just retired two weeks
ago tony james the number two at
blackstone which means what well i mean
some people know when to take the money
and run
okay so then but that tells me a
different story because what i'm trying
to get to is the following
so imagine a buyer's listing right now
or
he knows how to top the market
because he did it when he sold dlj how
old was he when he left tony james how
old is tony james tony james is probably
probably 70 maybe okay
fine 70 i mean it's it's you've made
your billions you want to go kick it a
little bit and schwartzman's 74. but
schwartzman is a psycho competitor you
know schwartzman is not a regular guy
schwartzman is like some of these guys
are not going to slow down if you ever
read his material the guy's freaking
sick i'm a schwartzman fan i think he's
a guy that i'm aware yeah he uh he's i
mean blackstone's real estate portfolio
loans about 56 billion dollars they bury
any any player in the private equity
real estate space and they were an lbo
lbo model right they were more of a
leveraged buyouts model though oh no no
no you you want to talk about the whole
thing yeah that's like 300 billion i
mean
they're a monster yeah yeah
so one question for you yeah so
before we go to the next story here's
one question so
average americans in average process
oriented jobs
work from home would sure help these
private equity firms that are building
these massive portfolios out from city
center wouldn't it the bureau of labor
statistics has reported that 11.1
percent of americans are now working
from home less than a third of what it
was at the peak of may 20. now they're
working from home 30 miles from downtown
like um and a giant american company
they're demanding that it's owned by the
private equity firm and they have a nice
school and a nice life okay higher rates
then then that's a shift of my that's a
paradigm shift that's a shift but we're
down to 11 percent it's with your point
you're correct for you said they're
thinking five ten years out yeah yes
these guys are not dummies i when i see
listen when i see
people like that they're not dummies
when when i see politicians that's a
difference remember they created this
model
now the rest of the world is following
them into this model yeah but are you
saying this is a negative i mean haven't
i mean it's basically a glorified
apartment complex with nicer homes it's
only a negative for the people paying
those rents
they're making that choice i mean some
people might want a nice house with a
pool you know that's 30 miles outside of
downtown they are making that choice
danielle you can't say dynamic they're
not but
but but we do know from the bureau of
labor statistics that in may of 2020
there were more than three times the
number of people working from home than
there are it's just eleven percent and
there used to be a moment where i'm
inside outside of new york and
california people are actually back in
the office just out of curiosity just i
mean out of a
the complete question that's off topic
but it is somewhat with the topic when
do you think everything will be back to
normal with covet
um
like a hundred percent like
2018 maybe never maybe never i don't
think business travels are ever coming
back the way it used to be okay but but
wait a minute you're saying are you part
of never camp well i'm part of the camp
that covet is being used politically and
as a weapon and i think they're going to
hold on to that as long as they can for
some degree so i don't think it'll ever
get back to how it used what do you
think i you know
i see a lot of busyness outside of new
york and l.a
i see a lot of normalcy oh so so you're
saying it's going to go back to normal
i'm saying i'm seeing a lot of normality
so what do you think what's your
timeline what do you think if you were
to guess they made them bet ten thousand
dollars what would you say is this
omicron thing whatever it is that's
apparently not as bad as no they've said
it they've said it right off the bat
it's not took a couple weeks to say it's
not that bad but there's going to be the
next of course that comes out right when
do you think it's going to be back to
normal i think we're going to get about
85 back to 80 85 back to the old normal
but there's going to be a bunch of new
normals like work from home for
processing job is a new normal less
business travel i think would be a new
normal but i think we're going to get
get back to a point where we go to the
restaurants you know the you can go to
the ball game you can go to a party at
an event place what's crazy is
everything you're saying in florida it's
all normal right like nothing's talking
nationals i know that's what i'm saying
like what you just said yeah without
california saying oh my god and being in
the nanny state yeah okay let's go to
the next story here let's go to the next
store let's see which one we want to go
to
jfk you guys want to go through that one
top secret jk assassination files are
finally released lee harvey oswald was
in contact with a member of a kgb two
months ago two months before shooting
and anonymous phone calls said russia
was behind it uh trove of 1500 documents
revealed this is on page
five uh biden said he wanted to do this
they finally did it more than 1500
public comments
100 kids okay they include memos
detailing anonymous phone calls from a
u.s embassy in cabrera in canberra
australia a year before the shooting
where the caller said the soviet
government was plotting to kill kennedy
and details of oswald's meeting with the
kgb agent at soviet embassy in mexico
city two months before the shooting
another call was placed on november 24th
two days before the shooting claiming
the russians were behind it earlier this
year robert f kennedy jfk's nephew which
i'm about to do debate with him in the
next two weeks with him and somebody
that he just wrote a book about fauci
and it's not the nicest book about
facebook it's amazing yeah you read it
i'm part of it i started a good friend
of mine turned me onto it who read it
and he told me all about it unbelievable
yeah we're doing it he's he's debating
somebody over the topic in the next
cheryl hines husband you know from curb
your enthusiasm yeah okay you've talked
to rfk before let me finish this time
let me finish this time and go so jfk's
nephew uh assumed that some of the files
would remain secret until next year how
the hell is it
58 years later and what in the world
would justify not releasing these
documents rfk said by the way these are
not all the files some of the files are
going to release next year and some of
them we may never find out about do you
think tom because i know you followed
this story you're somebody that's also
curious about this time you and i've
talked about this many times do you
think we're going to learn anything new
no i don't think so um there was the
speculation that um
you know that the russians were involved
that the you know that the cubans were
involved that felt betrayed by the bay
of pigs that the teamsters were involved
that sam giacono was involved and what i
find interesting here is they're all
pointing back to oswald which points
back to the single gunman theory which
is the one thing that every scientific
analysis of all the the echo and
everything in the tapes and clint hill
who you spoke to yep um
and the the last uh see i think he's the
last living person that was in the first
two cars so no you're saying nothing is
anybody thinking anything new is going
to come down
nothing never reveal the stuff that
actually tells you what happened because
somebody has to know do you have a crazy
theory on what you think happened like
10 seconds what do you think happened
two options internally mafia because the
dad joe or russia has to be involved
what do you think danielle i'm i'm with
i'm with my daddy was a bootlegger yeah
you know here's the thing how does a
secret like that stay a secret i mean
you i know people that we're when i go
places people tell me things i don't
know what it is you know people just
open up i learn who's sleeping with like
a priest they just feel comfortable
telling me things wow and i just
powerful i i don't know what it is maybe
it's my nice guy vibe or something but
how do people keep secrets like this how
does not one person reveal what happened
yeah how do we not know how is it even
possible someone has to know and it sure
is the heck isn't one gunman there's
just no way it's impossible i mean if
you go to the jfk you know the site
where you go to the building there's
just no way it's impossible they play
the tape and they show you four echoes
and then why was it so important to kill
him the next day i mean there's just
this is so fascinating i wish we could
learn there's a there's a lot of stuff
there i know
i interviewed jack barski two weeks ago
his interview came out yesterday jack
barski was a former kgb member from
germany he got recruited went to russia
they trained him and then he came out he
did espionage he did everything
so i showed him a video of uh
yuri besmanov if you've ever seen yuri
besmanov's interview before it's pretty
sick where he's talking about the whole
subversion and what they do and how they
train and how russia's trying to take
over us by getting their philosophies of
marxism and universities and professors
and teachers and get the youth and
eventually like today's modern day of uc
berkeley it's what they essentially were
talking about and they've been
successful
so i asked them all these other things
about the kgbs i was kgb involvement no
let me tell you what we did the kgb
number one
j edgar hoover was never a cross-dresser
we planted that
well done he says he was never a
cross-dresser we told him and threatened
them that we're gonna do that you know
what else the eighth scandal that was us
we made that eighth scandal in america
we did that i'm like dude i think you're
gaslighting me right now
but anyways no one's gonna know it's a
story
it's it's another great opportunity
right now for someone in hollywood
steven spielberg to make a jfk movie
right now
and bring the mob and you know maybe ty
you know godfather four coming out with
jfk's assassination link to it who knows
do you think the the immediate kennedy
family knows what happened
maria you know just maria
did jackie know
is it knowledge that's common at least
is known as one of the greatest
environmental attorneys america's ever
had okay that's what rfk's reputation is
right
in the environmental attorney side he is
the best right when he and i spoke the
first time i interviewed him i brought
up the whole jfk assassination
conversation this is a guy that
explained it in such an eloquent way
that to him he spent his entire lifetime
trying to find out what the hell
happened because it wasn't just his
uncle it was also his father it's
emotional to this guy so i guarantee you
they know more than you and i think uh
they know i
i buy that that i buy yeah i think i
think they know i think they know um
maybe we'll bring rfq what's really
interesting about conspiracies in
history what's that right so
the mob
always thinks a conspiracy is bigger and
there's more angles to it
but
the
when you take a look at the the mafia
and the conspiracy of kills around the
families
conspiracies only stay quiet long term
if there's a small group of people and
then what you always look for is the
second kill
and so when you take a look at what
happened with kennedy if oswald was one
of the gunman apparently he was then you
look at the second kill that was oswald
and so a small group of people that then
offs some of the people that were
executing it that's how the conspiracies
work and that's how they stay secret so
when you
look at things long term
if it's a big giant conspiracy
you know it always leaks out and the
truth kind of comes around when it's a
small conspiracy and you have the second
and the third kills then it stays quiet
so you're better off not knowing because
you might be dead no no no i mean like
oswald plus who else
was who was the guy there's one guy i
don't trust here's the one guy i don't
trust the one guy that i always just no
matter what i read i just don't get a
good feel about the guy is lyndon
johnson i just don't trust that yeah
nothing about that guy do i trust if you
read up his legacy the way he was wired
who he was he hated kennedy when kennedy
called him to be the vp he's like who
the hell do you think you are i'm
supposed to call you i'm the candidate
you don't call me and tell me to be the
vp i call you and tell you do you want
to be my vp i mean lyndon
that was his fastest way to being a
president
he was a pragmatist who knows i mean i'm
not telling you he did it all i'm
telling you is if he was that motivated
to be a president strategically he got
it done okay and his mistress had some
stories to say about it but
you're right in katherine graham's
biography who who used to be the
publisher of the washington
of the washington post she tells all the
bloody stories about the behind closed
door and lyndon johnson and how he he
and jfk he did he hated jfk
yeah and her husband was in the room 91
hours after the assassination lyndon
johnson started the vietnam war
after the french advisers had screwed up
and lift the tinderbox
i mean you just look at things like that
and it's it's a nasty nasty guy so
here's here's one thing
i think about
any president that was ever assassinated
or character assassinated typically
scared the hell out of the establishment
the establishment likes to pick who
becomes the next president the
establishment doesn't like you to pick
who becomes the next president the
establishment likes to pick who becomes
the next president as long as it's
within the crew of who we are okay cool
we're going to be fine because we'll
still have our card we'll still have our
parties we'll still have the country
club feeling all that other stuff you
bring one of these guys that lincoln out
of nowhere comes in or you get a
freaking uh you know reagan who goes
from hollywood and comes in and you were
finding communist and you want to come
in and be the president what are you
talking about you talking about john f
kennedy and your father who is joseph
kennedy we don't like people like you
trump we don't like people like trump so
um yeah i don't know i i don't know if
if the establishment likes people like
lincoln kennedy reagan or trump they're
not big fans of them not at all this is
this is why we ought to be very grateful
to having a person like biden right now
in the white house
you know because
you know it's just you found a positive
from him that's great for biden
i've been reading a lot of uh norman
vincent give me a break we've gone from
clinically insane to medically dead give
me a break danielle danielle but you
didn't support the alternative
what alternative when the obviously it
happened a year ago you didn't support
the alternative you have two choices
two choices between clinically insane
and medically dead yeah so so so i'm
proud to be an american
well what i'm saying to you is even a
year ago
who was our options we had two of them
yeah you had a trump and a biden i know
you did and they were both democrats
so you see you see trump as a democrat a
new york democrat who gave to both of
kamala's campaigns and they've got
kamala you know locked in it
in the basement somewhere by the way
there is a precedent you know we were
talking earlier about
biden being replaced
we forget that spiro agnew was replaced
during nixon's term so there is a
precedent for taking your vice president
out
just saying
well if it's this bad after one year
agnew was replaced for the equivalent of
a parking ticket nowadays well true and
then eight months later kennedy was uh
nixon was out of office
and then they put gerald ford in so is
it a form of blaming somebody else it's
like shifting blame is that kind of what
you're thinking
i i
from everything that i've heard
you can't even put biden and harris in
the same room together
he actually wakes up and gets angry
enough that he's like actually got a
pulse
huh that actually could be a good thing
though and no like that that can get
maybe they should put her in the room
right before right before good morning
it keeps them alive
they need to put her in the room right
before he goes up to the podium for the
press conference because it'll be like
oh
now we can do the conspiracy loop spro
agno gone gerald ford becomes the vice
president gerald forbes was on the
warren commission the warrant commission
investigated the kennedy assassination
general kennedy cheated
nixon gerald ford was a complete badass
i'm i'm going to stand up for gerald
ford here he was a military hero he was
a bad ass football player at michigan
yeah i mean two seasons undefeated
gerald ford was an amazing screwed up
tom amazing president okay you guys went
from sisters to now enemies in 30
minutes
let me change a story american let me
change the story gerald ford's a career
at the uh as a running back
i'm just messing around right now so
blumenthal speaks at communist party
award ceremony this is a washington free
beacon senator richard blumenthal
democrat from connecticut spoke at an
award ceremony over the weekend hosted
by a communist party affiliate whose
leaders used the event to recruit
potential members to members of the
organization blumenthal won the
wealthiest members of the senate
presented certificates of special
recognition from the senate to three
winners of the amistad award given
annually by the connecticut people's
world committee affiliate of the uh
communist party usa and the marxist
people world news site blumenthal was
introduced at the event by lisa
bergman a communist party member who
blamed corporations for imperialism that
exists in our world that is undermining
the labor environment
if you are not part of the communist
party we invite you to participate and
contribute and join bergman said after
blumenthal's speech there's more and
more people talking about socialism in
this country as it becomes more and more
clear that capitalism is not going to
work for our future
thoughts on that thomas
um well you have to remember can you
pull up blumenthal just pull up
blumenthal
capitalism builds the engine that is
running for taxes that
socialism uses because you cannot
perpetually print money otherwise you
end up like greece uh you know what in
1990 this guy did this
can you imagine the uproar remember the
anti-communist sentiment that was back
there and this guy had done this
15 years ago 25 years ago it would be
political death
it should be is he up for re-election
next year curious now take a look at the
picture he's up for embalming yeah
that's the most disturbing story in our
whole portfolio here today this one i
mean this one really pisses me off how
this guy can actually show his face
there and do this by the way he's worth
a hundred million dollars you know where
the money comes from his wife his wife
it's all real estate holdings by the way
they own part of the empire state
building i know that's part of their
their ownership stake is it's part of
their wealth is owning the empire state
building do you know who he beat just to
become a senator you know he beat he'd
be uh vince mcmahon's wife remember when
she ran linda mcmahon mcmahon back in
2010 so if we should have gone with the
wwe character back then we'd be in a
much better place but how can he do this
how how is he not just kicked out of the
senate this is unbelievable that he
would show his face here or be active
with this shocking i'm really shocked
because i literally i'm not being
inflammatory here you go back 25 years
you go by 15 years this guy would be on
the headlines of every news and would
have just been political death did you
see kevin o'leary and bill maher did you
see bill maher and kevin o'leary
together on the show can you pull up the
transcript kevin kevin o'leary and bill
maher so they he went up there and bill
maher okay
who is a
liberal
talks about capitalism
yeah exactly just let's plan anybody
just type in capitalism to come up uh
these people uh uh uh sharknews bill
maher workers are never i wanna show the
video i'm just worried if it's gonna
stay up or not that's the biggest
concern if it would stay up 28 seconds
if you don't understand click on that
real quick click on that real quick is
it their youtube channel or is it
twitter
um
[Music]
yeah we probably can't show that so you
may want to pause it so anyways they
talk to each other bill maher says i'm a
capitalist capitalism works capitalism
has been the system that's helped
america get to where we are today
so
then you get communism a speaker like
that speaks out of communism i wonder
what cnn is saying about blumenthal has
cnn said anything has msnbc said
anything interesting yeah because
there's got to be something we're all
together on
and cnn is shifting i mean see right now
cnn is shifting not centrist but they're
moving off of hard left in some of their
news coverage you hear it you see it on
the white house you see it on kamala
harris you hear it on saki so there's
something inside cnn that's turning the
dial from 11 down to about eight yeah
the survival i totally agree yeah and so
i want to hear one of those kind of pick
up on this
you want to hear what he says no i want
to hear one of these mainstream news
bits kind of call out these things and
talk about it look omarova stepped down
i mean
look
the the strange thing about what
blumenthal did is that the winds of
change have already blown virginia's
happened it's in the history books
and you know to to continue to insist
that this is gonna
i like what you said earlier
let's just sit back
eat popcorn pop open a beer and watch
the left side of the democratic party
rip itself apart it's in a civil war
right now okay so check this out i just
typed in blumenthal
type in blumenthal communist party and
then go to news
okay
i just
okay go go to all first go to offers
well there's the post okay
new york post okay i got it that's going
to be on one side
fox news fine yankee institute fine
national review there you go good so
let's see how national review puts it go
on national review go on national review
send room deliver switch communist party
let's see how they ride it how they
award it keep going up service dog one
of ours delivered a speech i don't know
where some commerce body bloomington
antenna event was uh
which was used uh in part to recruit new
members of the organization presented
certainly
you know the communist party is
affiliated with communist party okay
keep going a little higher keep going a
little higher i'm really excited about
an honor to be with you today and
sharing this remarkable occasion
blumenthal uses a special general
president biden's bill back better
agenda and democratization including
fifteen dollars in america the
connecticut democratic consultant
gentlemen holding corporations
accountable bloomberg was invited to
communist party and ceremonial person if
you are not already pocket i mean
there's nothing bad everybody is
largely because of his wife who is a
member of the new york real estate
dynasty he has come under fire for being
unaware of all of his investments
including in the u.s shanghai llc real
estate company connected to chinese
government according to washington free
beacon go a little lower go a little
lower
call the lord okay yeah i mean look if
if you again if you guys are not on the
same page about communism not being this
this was already addressed 50 years ago
you thought you thought this was over
with yeah exactly this is political
treason if you ask me i mean to go out
there and support communism like this
and you asked if he's up for a
re-election he was elected in 2010 so he
will be up in 2022 every six years
a citizen of the state of connecticut
maybe he's out thinking all of us and
he's making himself such an unattractive
candidate to make sure that it flips in
connecticut and you get republican in
there well let's go to a different story
let's look at the low literacy levels
among u.s adults could be costing the
economy 2.2 trillion dollars this is on
page three
a new study of galileo this is a forbes
story a new study by gallup on behalf of
barbara bush foundation for family
literacy finds that low levels of adult
literacy could be cost in the us as much
as 2.2 trillion dollars a year according
to the u.s department of education 54 of
us adults 16 to 74 about 130 million
people
lack proficiency and literacy reading
below the equivalent of a sixth grade
wait let me say that one more time
i'm blown away right now according to us
department of education 54 of us adults
16 to 74 okay that's 130 million people
lack proficiency and literacy reading
below the equivalent of a sixth grade
level the average annual income of
adults who are at minimum proficiency
levels for literacy level three is below
sixty three thousand dollars
significantly higher than the average
roughly forty eight thousand dollars
earned by adults who are just below
proficiency level two and much higher
than those levels at level zero and
which is 34. if all u.s adults were able
to move up at least to level three
literacy profession proficiency it would
generate an additional 2.2 trillion
dollars of annual income uh in the
country equal to 10 of gdp tom it's
unbelievable if you had read me the
details of this story and said what is
the percentage of this being true i'd
say
one percent i'd say there is no way that
this is but it is true and it's it's
incomprehensible 130 that's
over a third of us right now over well
over based on a 335 census and yet
you've got this i mean you know and then
you have these big cities where it's
really really bad you know in la new
york chicago san francisco f's you know
they said if these big cities if if 10
percent
they said the gdp would increase more
than 10 in these big cities if they just
got everybody up to the sixth grade
level that is mind-boggling and here
think about this too what's happened in
the last year
kids aren't learning anything that's
right right especially in big school
districts in the big cities it's a
wasted year and it's probably a wasted
three or five years because they don't
care parents can't force them to go to
school so now you're raising a whole new
generation that can't read or won't read
and it's the most easily fixable problem
there is i mean if you think about it to
teach people to have you know just
remedial english skills it's not that
difficult if the country wanted to you
know embark on kind of difficult to get
rid of teachers unions though so
what do you think about this danielle
what do you think about this i think
this is the teachers unions
can you unpack that
look if if covet has taught us anything
it's that the teachers are not advocates
for the students the teachers are
advocating advocates for themselves and
school districts the way that they're
designed the the money goes to the
administration there's way too much in
the way of management you don't pay
teachers enough we've learned that you
can you know
you could theoretically just go virtual
you could go virtual in the classroom
you could hire somebody for a million
dollars a year
a rock star teacher and have him teach
the kids and have him be engaged kind of
like
i don't know a jay leno or something but
just pay him a ton of money and then
teach these kids and you could do that
but you'd have to disband the unions
wait time out you saying that you could
do that virtually because i don't think
kids would no no no no no no no i am i
am saying that you can do virtual
teaching if you get somebody who kids
are like hot damn
i'm talking about like a rock star
i'm saying deplete the pool of educators
in this country to where you get it to
where you're you're talking about people
who are so engaging that people are like
this is better than tick tock i've gotta
i've gotta go see this person because
you you don't pay you don't pay teachers
enough and you pay administrators too
much and it's the structure of teachers
unions and they've screwed over children
and i think that they should be i think
collective bargaining should be
made unconstitutional i look at teachers
unions right now and this has only
happened in the last year year and a
half they're a political organization
they always have been though yeah but
they're more in your face about it now
and it's more evident that that's their
strategy yeah
and it's all this great inflation and or
deflation whatever
just let them pass you know give them
trophies for participating i can't
believe this a sixth grade reading level
that's unbelievable by the way let me
tell you why i like this i like this
because
you know it's it's selling me
so so but this is being written by who
can can you look at who wrote this
article who's the person that wrote this
article don't i know it's forbes but i
want to know who wrote it right but you
got to be careful of forbes i thought
ford's his own video
forbes did this
on a big government but go to that
article tyler and let's see who wrote it
that's like the usda report that said
that food stamps need to go by 32
that one
editor's pick michael who is he
is a contributor he's a contributor i'm
a former
university president who writes higher
education go google him
google him
uh take his name and just google them
yeah
i don't know maybe i went in college i
was awarded ph in clinical psychology
from university of 1973.
all right let's see who you are
as a retired national missouri
university professor
um and prior to that was provost of uh
university of kentucky after retired as
president of the terms of missouri
governor jay nixon okay governor jay
nixon i i hope he's the one who read
this 52 minutes ago the intellectual
freedom that made public colleges great
is under threat
no the intellectual freedom that
made public college is great
okay go washington post go uh by the way
tom who's jay nixon washington post is
trying to do a little bit of cnn former
governor of missouri right i get that
but i mean who is he like what was he
uh uh okay democratic party he's
probably honored
okay it's very hard to be a heart go to
his twitter account go to mike's twitter
account
there's a psychologist whatever
camera
intellectual freedom that may poke okay
go to that second article right there
with washington post yeah right there
click on that
the intellectual frame that made public
college great is under threat uh family
members at public universities are under
fire in numerous states faculty members
at pogba university
the face they face a serious and grown
threat to the academic freedom that lets
them choose their research topics and
determine what happens in their
classrooms without political politicians
looking over their shoulders across the
nation state legislators are proposing
laws to limit the teaching of certain
viewpoints on campus curb the 10-year
system or otherwise blur the already
thin line between higher education and
state politics if states continue down
this path they will undercut the
excellence of their own institutions of
higher education some of which will
currently be counted among the best
universities in the world they could
send these institutions to down roads
right around the gap of information
intellectual freedom secured at private
university okay that's good this is good
conversation that they're having a
sentence in the last paragraph there
offend the wrong on-campus constituency
and university administrators will soon
be lobbied to have the offending scholar
banished from campus this is great but
this is great i like this conversation
that guy's got the right tone yeah to me
to me uh i want to know what the dems
and republicans agree on
what do we agree on can we agree that
china is enemy to state number one yes
okay great can we agree that communism
doesn't work yes can we agree that
socialism doesn't work yes can we agree
that the best social programs are
created by a capitalistic system yes
let's go through these things that we
agree on okay why don't we all let's
disagree on whatever you want to
disagree on who reformed welfare bill
clinton yeah
then let's go
write these things that we agree on
because the direction this article is
going to edu to challenge people to get
better listen to telling you you go
increase your value in the marketplace i
love that i think that's fantastic that
that conversation is being had andrew
cuomo ordered to return 5.1 million
pandemic book profits to state
uh you think that'll ever happen
uh new york this is a new york post
story new york's top ethics panel on
tuesday ordered disgrace ex governor
cuomo to pay the state uh 5.1 million
dollars in book profits he made on the
backs of taxpayers amid the worst of the
public of kobe 90 pandemic the
extraordinary resolution was approved by
the joint commission on public ethics a
month after the ethics agency voted to
revoke its uh prior approval allowing
cuomo to earn outside income from his
book american crisis leadership
while he was still governor in new york
was in the thrones of the deadly
coronavirus they rescinded its approval
after concluding that cuomo violator
pledges not to use the state's resources
or government staffers to prepare the
book he must pay the money to the state
by next month do you think this is going
to happen hold my beer
you know i
where were you when he was writing this
book everybody was you know so
supportive of him and they loved him
they should reclassify this book from
non-fiction to fiction right now now for
what we know of how he handled kovid
yeah so the advance was five million he
says he got 2 million right a million he
put in a trust for his daughters a
million of that 500 000 he gave to
charity there's no way they're going to
claw back any of this money here's the
thing with the cuomo's these guys are
such fighters i mean these are these
guys are brawlers they're old man the
former mario cuomo the old governor of
new york i mean he was a tough dude i i
think it's going to be fascinating to
see what happens with chris cuomo too
right because someone has to scoop him
up these guys will tell secrets i think
i don't think chris cuomo believed
everything he said when he was on cnn
and these guys i
i i think this is a treasure trove of
information if you could get chris cuomo
to open up about some of these i think
fox news should hire him by the way but
here's the other thing i saw from this
story is the fbi is investigating it as
well to see because he had staffers
working on this book which is illegal
allegedly right so he had a lot of his
staff doing the research helping to
write this book and and uh and you can't
do that so they have some i think some
legal grounds to try to go after this
money but he's going to fight it and he
already heard the quotes from his lawyer
he said i'll see you in court so
what do you think
i'm with you i think i think i'm i'm
italian so
everything he said i agree with and
mario was a badass yeah mario and
they're likely
and i think your idea about fox news is
brilliant
by the way with that story with uh fox
news story being brilliant you saw
wallace went to cnn right on their app
and then howard stern says who gives a
no one no one watches cnn's apps
anyway so what are you going on there
for uh and then uh what's it called
brian williams uh uh uh resigned he left
yes bye-bye yeah so he leaves wallace to
cnn
what do you think about what's going on
here
what did that negotiation sound like
with wallace was it kind of like well
cnn you ain't looking too good i think
it's a good time you hire a conservative
i'm a good guy to hire because i'm
pretty safe but here's what i want from
you if you give me these things i'll
come if you don't i'm not coming and a
sienna needed that victory to say we got
somebody from fox you think that's the
play no i don't know because if you take
a look chris wallace he was not
expensive brian williams was very
expensive what was fox payne chris
wallace
pox
well brian williams was like at four and
a half a year and they were stuck with
him because it was this long-term
contract and then he had the you know i
was being chased by helicopters with
gunfire and everything like this and the
lies that he told about all that yeah i
think he was making more than four seven
million wallace was paying paid seven
million wow that's insane i'm telling
you right now you know he made seven
million it was private
15 20. i mean when he was when he was
doing nightly news he was making 15
years
you know but but you're right patrick
there's a lot of shuffling going on
chris wallace right now chris wallace
also has the name mike wallace you know
he's got the lineage there so there's
10 million
chris wallace is a democrat and a lot of
fox news watchers were getting
irritated with him
just like they were shepard smith
i thought he was a fantastic journalist
wallace there's a very very very very
memorable that he did with bill clinton
bill clinton came out of his shoes and
was leaning into his face right into his
grill yeah remember when he moderated
the debate and everybody was all over
chris wallace because he wasn't hard
enough on the democrats you could kind
of see that you know he really did and
after 18 years with fox news you
probably want to go somewhere else and
have a little bit different perspective
spin that you can put on stories and i
think it's it's not just a show it's
it's cnn digital right so it's going to
be a different type of format he
probably just needed a challenge in his
career yeah but it's just like i mean
katie who bill o'reilly has faded into
the
uh oblivion yeah yeah
and katie but but different
circumstances he was ousted because of
sexual harassment true and nobody else
hired him you know he's going to be
front and center at cnn be the face of
their digital
i bet they paid him 12. what do you
think brian's going to be doing next
brian williams i couldn't find cnn
digital if you i can't even google cnn
digital i don't think there's any uh i
don't think there's any market for brian
williams whatsoever i don't think he'll
get a job i don't think he'll get a high
level network job no way and i don't see
him being savvy enough to go the glenn
beck route or anything like that and he
doesn't have any particular views that
you buy into i never bought brian
williams in general because he does not
have a magnetic position there's not a
magnetic position the way there always
was for rush there always was for back
there always was for hannah you know
what i'm saying they have that center
that's at the cult of personality
i think you have to have enemies to be
cult-like brian williams wasn't
necessarily a guy that had too many
enemies he'll be like matt lauer just
fade away in the hamptons what the
warning immediate discovery deal means
for cnn and jeff sucker what am i
looking at cnn's about to be acquired by
warner media and their ratings are
obviously tanking so you have to wonder
between chris wallace chris cuomo etc
what are they trying to do are they
trying to shake things up they're trying
to get more moderate to bring their
ratings up like they have to do
something they're a sinking jeff zucker
has no clout in the deal have you
noticed that
going to it he's got no position coming
out of the deal discovery's going to run
the thing it's a good point you make
tyler there so so what what are you
saying are you saying um
are you saying like they have to become
moderate because no one wants nobody
wants to buy cnn type of business i
don't i don't think they have to become
moderate per se but they have to move
away from the far left almost
propagandist brainwashing but get away
from the brian stelters and and and that
kind of stuff is which is where a chris
wallace sort of moderate can come in and
change things up i think jeff zucker
will be possibly gone after this like
you look at what they did after bringing
back jeffrey tubin yeah i mean it's they
they've just completely shot themselves
in the foot and they have to do
something
where do you get your news from what do
you watch
well i don't i don't listen to anything
i watch bloomberg you watch bloomberg
well but because it's bloomberg tv it's
got like information i got you that's a
different story though yeah yeah that's
a different story
the 35 000 year type of deal you talk
about that you talk about the membership
of bloomberg no i mean i mean the
television station bloomberg tv because
it's got all the information on it i got
you i mean but you don't listen to you
don't watch or listen to anybody
is there anybody that you would say i
kind of like hearing this person's
perspective or two
i think um remember my second master's
is in journalism so i totally believe in
the the idea of fair and balanced so i
think i think brett bear is a is a good
is a good journalist i'll i'll watch him
on the evening news you know if
you know if i had to watch the evening
news but i don't i watch bloomberg asia
tom how about yourself uh in the morning
it's cnbc squawk on the street morning
bell i think and i like the way that
they put new stories in and they kind of
just give you a like a
middle-of-the-road cover glitzy it's all
that's all entertainment i just want
them no and then information no but then
i go to then i go bounce back and forth
between fox business and cnn business
and you know all scan you know a bunch
of uh news grabs like um
business insider i'll scan that but um i
don't have one guy that that is my go-to
you know i used to be such a news junkie
i worked in news i was an anchor for 15
years i don't watch any news i do not
sit down and watch a local newscast or a
national newscast but i can't local news
is scary yeah i consume information all
day but there's a lot of i just i forced
myself to get a balance and you know
what cnn is unwatchable but cnn business
is is a very tolerable site to read i
have no problem reading cnn business
i like reading new york post you know i
like the daily mail sometimes but you
always get bought you get sucked into
the agenda that they all have and they
all have some sort of agenda so i just
tell everybody just to you know
don't go deep on watching news i mean it
will ruin your life
is becoming woke i mean it's really
difficult right now to to not it's
really difficult to find just
unvarnished information
that's not in some way tainted by the
editorial team you can't even
i've got friends who work inside the
wall street journal who work inside the
financial times well here's one great
example pat did you hear about this
story so sunday night football michelle
tafoya is the sideline reporter right so
she hasn't been on the games for the
last three or four weeks i saw that okay
so now they just announced that she's
not coming back this is going to be her
last year and nbc said that she wasn't
working the previous few weeks because
it was a bye week for her which makes
zero sense all right why would you have
your star sideline reporter take a week
off you know when the nfl season only
goes 17 games so what happened about a
month ago is she was on the view and she
sat in the conservative chair okay so
for one day she was on the view and she
said on the view that day that she
thought kovid was more like flu right
she downplayed the significance of covet
and since then she's been whitewashed
she's been banished she hasn't been on
the sidelines and now she's done and
pretty much that's why people are saying
it's happening she will have a job
within 30 days if she wanted to michelle
tafoya is a beast she's not going to
have a hard time finding a good job
she's smart and she's multi-sport and
she doesn't need the producer in her ear
she reads the games really well yeah
yeah she's not going to have look look
if she wants to look how quickly she'll
end the job michelle if you're listening
or if anybody knows michelle reach out
to valuetainment
we would actually offer a job too
because she's a monster exactly she
loved the way she uh
her salaries are drawn to earnings if
only we had someone on staff that was
already looking forward okay check this
out so uh uh what her salary is 1.96
million no net worth is 1.96 her salary
is 27 000 a month that's what her salary
is and i'm serious it's what's showing
right now 27 000 a month
abtc.ng so someone's gonna pick her up
so she gets six grand a game
here's uh two hundred thousand dollars a
year is the two hundred thousand dollars
here's what her salary is remember espn
doesn't pay as well as people think they
right people think espn pays very well
nfl refs make more than that they make
way more than that
and and michelle is
got a lot of clout she's got a lot of
credibility yeah she's been around a
long time she's she's
57 you hit news i like how michael she's
awesome so she hasn't taken anything yet
she's multi-sport she's covered in black
that's what you're saying on the floor
yeah
changing islamic calling campaign oh she
also slammed nbc's michelle okay let me
pull this one up because you just
brought it up
long time nbc sports sideline reporter
michelle tiforce changing roles after
criticizing colin kaepernick's netflix
series for liking the nfl to slavery
during november episode of the view uh
and
i remember this uh back and forth with
what she said no one uh pressures them
so this was again on the view no one
pressures them she told view co-host
sunny hostin huston on november third
episode prompting criticism on social
media they're not forced to go into the
nfl tafoyo who has uh been on the nfl
sidelines et cetera et cetera i mean if
you haven't seen it you got to watch it
she's a beast she stood her ground when
she spoke to those guys she definitely
this to the standard ground
san francisco democratic mayor london
breed after backing defunding police
reverses need aggressive policing so now
these folks are realizing
cops are good okay that's a good sign
we're going in the right direction
we're keeping count here right china's
bad communism is bad and cops are good
okay that's right that's by the way
that's what i like now we're realizing
what we agree on right san francisco
reverses
a far-left movement that is well outside
the mainstream is now calling those same
progressive policies the that
has now destroyed our city breeds
remarks appear to contrary to her prior
position when she came out and supported
the far left defund the police movement
the wake of the death of george floyd
last year saying that the incident
brought forward the devastating impacts
of police violence against african
americans in the country in july 31 2020
statement breed said that the she was
seeking to divert more than 100 million
dollars from the san francisco police
department to social justice programs
what happened so look nothing prior this
block used to be for first-time home
buyers then global investors bought in
ba
bigger and bigger so this block of the
neighborhood used to be for first-time
home buyers then global investors the
story is going to be grande look
she had a problem san francisco has had
this issue for
10 years long before the unfortunate
situation terrible situation with the
loss of george floyd and things went
along with that
she ran on clean the city up and
she got there
on
liberal policies but there was also an
undercurrent of we got to do something
because this has been going on for 10
years that was her original position
she moved her position been to the
political pressure because she had to
follow
everything that happened she had to
follow the defund she had to follow that
she had no freaking choice that wasn't
what she wanted to do and now you're
seeing exactly the person that ran for
mayor
coming back saying you know what the bs
that destroyed our our city she doesn't
want to be on the hook for it you know
you know what you know what i like tom
let me tell you why i i'm okay with that
here's why i am too i think she's coming
back to the original position but here's
what happened two years ago the board
made a suggestion on what they wanted to
do i think you remember this two years
ago they said let's change the comp
structure to xyz okay one of our board
members didn't like the way i had the
comp set up and i said i just want you
know if we change the comp to this
here's what the side effects are going
to be he says i don't know let's do it
anyways i said no problem for two months
we did exactly what the ask was those
two months the numbers dropped 30
percent for those two months then in
march when we did that meet do you
remember the conversation in march we
did the meeting here's what the board
said you know what
this didn't work patrick maybe you're
right yeah that was kind of the board
meeting and we went back to what it was
and guess what happened
everybody now believed in the comp
structure there's a part of me that
thinks that's okay it's okay for us to
test certain messaging time to see how
it goes we learned defund the police was
a terrible idea guess what now it's
fully documented so now nobody can go
back to cops or bad of course there's
bad cops of course there's all this
other stuff but we need cops 9-1-1 is a
powerful method that's the first thing
you think about when somebody breaks
into your place you should still be able
to have that luxury yeah that's really a
point and the board learned in a very
straightforward way
that the motivations of sales forces and
years gone by doesn't necessarily apply
today so they learn too yeah and now
they don't dispute it now they're
thinking and helping in ways show don't
tell
two things she's probably dealing with
would anybody in their right mind think
of going to san francisco on vacation
right now you it wouldn't even enter
your your thought process and it used to
be a glorious city can you imagine the
tourism dollars that they're they're
missing out oh my gosh i mean i used i
used to go every six months just for a
long weekend it's amazing i mean i went
to college it was just amazing it was a
great place it was magical and no longer
it's it's a hell hole right now but for
her to say
destroying our city for a woke mayor
like that to say that that's great
though i agree and here's the thing the
people that they were catering to that
they want to protect those people are
not political so when this rampant crime
is hitting they don't give a crap who
they're hitting i mean who they're
affecting and i guarantee a lot of her
donors and supporters are business
owners that are getting crushed and
they're feeling pressure right now which
is which is forcing them to do this so
next in line hopefully is chicago
lightfoot hopefully it's garcetti before
he heads off to india and what's your
guys take on the new mayor in new york
he's going to be a better alternative
isn't he yes could anybody be worried
i mean
he's a he's a touch over toward the
moderate side although he's not a pure
play moderate but he's leaning backwards
in new york he's the he's the right guy
for new york much better
oh my gosh yes i mean diversity of
communists tore down thomas jefferson's
statue in front of city hall
two people that destroyed cities garcon
the the district attorney in los angeles
and
de blasio in new york two people i don't
think have done more damage to the major
cities than anybody else in history we
need to get december 31st here and get
him out of office you know in san
francisco she's at odds with the um with
the d.a
you know san francisco of course because
he was soros soros's guy the dea correct
so she said that's a good sign that's
great that's fantastic attention there
you know the guy that refuses to
prosecute anybody and then she who
doesn't want to lose her job as mayor
she was elected to in the next election
because people are like
and i think she's correct she's coming
out saying the bs that destroyed our
city she got put in a a horrible vice at
the middle of just a huge sway
of what was happening in america at the
time and she got pinched right into it
and she
she didn't want all of it and she went
with it and now look she has to come
back i think bale is going to make a
comeback in big cities what is bail bail
make bail great again
no it's make bail high
again see make baileys we'll let you out
on your own reconnaissance if you
promise to come to court okay and and
don't rush no more smash and grabs don't
rock promise don't rob that other bodega
tomorrow
no question no no jeremy no no jeremy
one more time
question for you guys are you optimistic
about 2022
i am i'll answer that question right
away because i'm seeing some signs here
and plus there's there's an opportunity
for real change to happen so i am
optimistic hell yeah
i remember i'm optimistic about 2022 but
i think it's going to be a painful
process but i'm optimistic of what's
going to come out on this
painful process i think it's going to be
a painful process with the economy it's
going to be a painful process for people
like uh mayor london breed i think it's
going to be a painful process throughout
the year with the next wave of covid but
we're going to get down to the midterm
election i think we're going to look
back at the end of the year and say wow
i'm glad 2022 is over but i think we
made some progress here here and here
yeah i um i i think that there's
probably a recession in our future that
people are not anticipating i don't
think this can be an easy year 2020 to
get to the end of the year
but however let me see what she has to
say
look um
with with any luck because it's a
midterm year there's not going to be
some crazy fiscal spending to the rescue
because you won't be able to pass the
legislation i think tester and cinema
and mansion have drawn the line and i
think they're going to hold the line so
i think even if we do have a recession
it's not going to be
totally
it with more fiscal
just insanity so again and that will
that will probably boost the midterm
chances and i think the country's ready
for change
i just i hope the republicans that have
also
spent like drunken sailors don't win
back the house and the senate and then
spend on what they want to spend on and
run the debt up even more i really want
for all of this rhetoric to actually be
sincere and for us to actually step back
and say we need to look at entitlement
spending this is fiscal spending gone
wild we really need to step back and
that's what mansion's been saying we
need to step back
and so i'm hoping that politicians in
the in in the center and obviously the
gop i'm hoping that they prevail but
then stop
and
pause and say
you know what we had some really crappy
policies after the pandemic hit
the dow is 36 000 today
next year today will it be higher or
lower
well next year next year will be higher
or lower
i think it's going to be flat year over
year okay because there's a lot of
forces you think it'll be a flat year i
think it'd be a flat year
you think recession is going to take
affect the uh dow tremendously if a
recession comes yeah i don't think it
would be flat like this i think this can
be one of these
okay i think we're going to see it we've
seen volatility we've seen volatility
come back and i think that we need to
get used to that we
the current generation of investors is
kind of like like on prozac
has been but the bumpiness that we've
been experiencing i think you better
just buckle up buttercup because it's
it's going to stay bumpy so what do you
think the number will be the end of next
year
no clue
i say down because i think it's going to
go down but i think that the midterms
will bring it up but that's november i
think the better question is to ask if a
recession happens is it going to
negatively impact the market
yes because
saving the market last time required not
just the federal reserve to ride to the
rescue but the fiscal
authorities to ride to the rescue you
needed a double-barrelled approach
so the fed can't go at it alone and
during a midterm election year there's
not going to be some massive fiscal
spending bill
mitch mcconnell won't have it you just
hope mansion doesn't retire or step away
that's it i don't think he will anybody
has not seen
if anybody's not seen the
the bloomberg interview of him david
rubinstein from the car log group he
interviewed mansion recently and it was
epic it was so awesome so catch that
fantastic we will definitely do that
awesome okay great show guys
uh we will not have a show next week
on monday i'm hosting a
business planning workshop uh that we'll
be doing a lot of you guys asked about
it we're finally doing it it'll be a
zoom uh that will do business planning
workshop all day from uh eight til eight
at night uh if you haven't yet
registered we're gonna put the link
below for you to go register for this
business planning workshop if 2021 was
an okay year for you and maybe you had
less than 50 of your goals and you want
to increase the number of percentages of
goals you hit you may want to join us
for that business planning workshop
it'll be myself and tom next monday
register we'll see you there having said
that we are not going to see you until
after christmas so merry christmas
christmas all of you christmas we'll see
you after that take care everybody bye
bye bye
you